[تصفيق]
اليوم انا راح اعرف عن حالي ثلاث مرات مش
عارف عن حريم مره واحده
فاكيد
محمد شاكر طقس بس اليوم راح اعرف حلب طرق
مختلفه تمام
حنبلش اول اشي بهذه الصوره بتعرفوا ايش
هذه الصوره
هاي صوره
فيلم اسمه ذا وذر مان
هذا ممثل نيكولا مثل بفيلم قصه وذر مان
شخص كان بين قوسين ما حدا بيحب يسمع له او
يصدقه
وضل مصر على انه تنبؤاته صحيحه لحد ما صار
مسمي ذا وذر مان في الدوله اللي كان فيها
بحس انه في شويه شبه
بيني وبينه شويه يعني في شويه شبه بيني
وبينه
هاي صوره لالي انا صغير يعني تشابه بيني
هلا بدي اعرفكم عن حالي
انا اسمي محمد الشاكر شخص
عندي شغف وهوايه بشكل كبير كبير في الطقس
والاحوال الجويه
[موسيقى]
طيب ايش صار بعدين اللي صار انه انا عمري
ثمان سنوات
وسبع سنوات وست سنوات كنت مجنن
اهلي
بالطقس والاحوال الجويه
بعد فتره استسلموا الى الواقع
والدتي
اخذتني على دائره الارصاد الجويه حتى ابلش
اتعلم هذا العمر قديش 11 سنه 12 سنه
بلشت اروح على دائره الارصاد الجويه بدل
ما كنت اطلع كل يوم خميس وانا في المدرسه
صرت اروح وين على الارصاد الجويه ايش اعمل
احاول اتعلم منهم كيف بيعملوا تنبؤات جويه
وخرائط جويه ويقرا سوره اشتغل معهم كاني
عم باخذ شفت معهم لدرجه انه في بعض
الاوقات كنت اروح معهم شفت الليل اللي هو
24 ساعه يعني ليله خميس جمعه بعد ما اخلص
مدرسه روح
وبحيك بصراحه على ثقه انك انت كنت واثقه
انه انا رايح فعلا على الارصاد وانام برا
البيت عشان اتعلم هذا الشيء
صار شويه اهداف بعديها فارغه اول شيء انا
في ال 2003 كان عمري تقريبا حوالي 13 سنه
14 سنه
ما كان في شيء اسمه انترنت زي مليون متوفر
الانترنت على الموبايل انا لا انا من
الاجيال لا حكيت ما في انترنت
على الموبايل
فقررت اني افتح مدونه بلوك هلا يعني
بس على وقتي ما كان في اصلا مواقع
الكترونيه هاي المدونه كانت تعنى بكتابه
ايش عم بيصير في احداث جويه
هاي المدونه هاي اول مدونه انا فتحتها كان
كنت تقريبا حوالي 13 سنه
14 15 سنه بتعرفوا مع قرب كاس العالم كثير
منكم بشجع كره القدم كان في منتديات وما
زال لي كره القدم
يعني بناس بتحلل في كره القدم
اللي صار انه طب انا حكيت ليش ليش ما في
منتديات طقس سالت حالي ليش ما في منتدى
طقس ناس بتشارك فيه وبتحكي عن هواياتها
وما الى ذلك
فروحت قررت اني افتح طقس
وهي اول شكل للمنتزهات هذا الحكي كان انا
عمري تقريبا 14 او 15 سنه هذا المنتدى
اكتسب شهره صار عليه كثير ناس كثير بشكل
نسبي ايش يعني كثير
يعني انا كنت متوقع مثلا يكون في ثلاثه في
العالم زيي او 5 في العالم عنده نفس هذه
هوايه شفت انه العدد بالمئات
وهذاك الوقت ما كان في انترنت لما يكون في
مسجل 500 معناته في شيء في هذا الموضوع
شوي في البدايه كانت خطوات كثير مهمه
للقصه على بين ما بدات هناك احداث انا
بسميها تواريخ التحول احداث كانت جدا
مؤثره اول هدف اثنين اثنين 2006 ده تاريخ
انا ما راح انساه
هذا التاريخ انا كنت بعرف اقرا خرائط في
ذلك الوقت فشوفت انه في احتمال كثير كبير
ليسير في سيول
2006 لو ترجع بالكلام ده راح تلاحظ انه
هذا اليوم يوم خميس على ما اعتقد وكان هذا
اليوم هو يوم الخميس كان يوم عطله فانا
قلت راح يصير في سيول في الجنوب طب لازم
نخبر الناس بلاش من الناس تطلع كان الجو
حلو قبل يومين شوي بدايه ربيع بعد ما خلص
شهر واحد
فاثرت وحكيت مع حدا وكالات الانباء وحكيت
لهم انه راح يكون في سيول فعلا منطقه بعد
اربعه ايام او ثلاث ايام او يومين ناس ايش
كانت الفتره لكن حكيت له انه في سيول طبعا
الخط اللي كنت انا بحكي فيه ايش صار فيه
ولد صغير
ونبهوا الناس
كان في استغراب ايش صار يوم 2/2006 الاسد
توفى اشخاص بسبب السيول في جامعه تليفون
انه في ناس توفت بسبسوله كيف انت عرفت انه
في سيول كانت صدمه لانه انا عالي هوايه
والمعلومه فعليا تقدر تحمي ارواح ناس تقدر
فعلا
بدانا نقتنع
انا واللي معي في المنتدى هذا الفريق اللي
بدا عنده نفس هذا الشجر انه قد تكون
المشكله هي عباره عن طريقه ايصال المعلومه
الجويه ممكن في 2006 لما بلش الانترنت
يدخل للنشر يمكن تيجي مره واحده على
التلفزيون لازم تصير على الانترنت
عشان هيك بدانا نعمل موقع الكتروني مين
بدانا ما فيش حدا انا سويت اتعلمت برمجه
وعملت موقع الكتروني هاي شكله هذا موقع
حقيقي
[موسيقى]
لانه انا كنت مصر انه لازم يكون في موقع
بعد هاي الحادثه
حادث الثاني الفارقه كانت في 27 12 2006
صادف عده امور
صادف نهايه السنه الميلاديه عطل اعياد
الميلاد المجيد كان عيد الاضحى في هداك
الوقت فكان في عطله طويله شفت على الخرائط
انه في عاصفه ثلجيه قويه جدا على جنوب
الاردن وقلت لازم انه نحكي للناس مادام في
عطله جاي شو راح يصير راح تتنقل الطلاب
اللي بجمعات الشمال اذا ساكنين بالجوهر
يروحوا على الجنوب والعكس صحيح
النتيجه كانت يوم 27/12 انه الاف الاشخاص
تحاصروا وناموا في العراق
طريق الصحراوي
دخل دخلت الدوله عن طريق الطائرات لانقاذ
الناس هنا اكدت على انه لازم ابدا واكمل
في الشيء اللي انا فيه لانه شيء فعلا مهم
هاي الخريطه
شويه ازرق واحمر هاي خريطه ارصاد جويه انا
صممتها وعملتها برمشتها لما كان عمري اقل
من 18 سنه
تتعدى حدود القدرات المنطقيه
الشخص لما بيكون عنده الصراع وشغف بطل في
منطق لو اليوم انا رحت ورجيت هاي الخريطه
لاي شخص وانا عمري 33 سنه اليوم بالمناسبه
هيحكيلك طبيعي تعلمت درسين سويت وانتجت
هذا الشيء هذا الشيء انا انتجته والواني
ومعلومات جويه وانا لسه ما كان عمري 18
سنه
طيب شو الحدث الثالث اللي كان نقطه التحول
في 25/11 او 26/11
كان حج ويوم عرفه صار في سيول جاري في جده
وهذا المنظر برده
هاي سيارات
جرفت بالسيول كانت كارثه بمعنى الكلمه
عرفت ان المشكله الي كنا نحكي فيها قبل
شويه يعني في الاردن هي مشكله ايش
وطن عربي فان ولد طقس العرب
بطريقه ايصال النشره الجويه كان لازم
تتطور بدل ما تكون تلفزيون لازم تكون عن
طريق الانترنت بدل الانترنت تصير اه بدل
موقع اه بدل فقط
هذا الاعتقاد اللي كان موجود
فبلاش نطور نعمل هذا الموقع الالكتروني
بعدين فجاه واجهنا مشكله كبيره
مضحكه
اطلع بحكي بكره في ثلج
ثاني يوم الصبح ايش بلاقي الشمس قبل ما
تشرق الشمس
بكره يصير في ثلج
في مشكله هلا انا فريق العمل كنا عارفين
انه مش مشكلتنا هاي مش مشكله خرائط هاي
مشكله بيانات بس تكون دائما اقول لهم انه
احنا لازم نجلد ذاته لانه دائما اي حدا
راح يجي يزور هذا الموقع
ما عنده فرصه ثانيه ما عندك انت كشخص فرصه
ثانيه الانتباه الاول
من خلال هذه المقوله اللي انا تبنيتها قلت
لازم انه حتى لو المشكله في الخرائط لازم
نحل مشكله الخرائط مشكله البيانات حتى لو
هذا الموضوع شبه مستحيل لانك انت ما رح
يكون عندك فرصه ثانيه
انت اليوم دخلت على الموقع ولقيت كل
التوقعات غلط كثير نسبه كبيره مره ثانيه
ولانه اي ام برشن انت بتتركه هو حقيقه اي
انطباع انا بتركه او انت بتتركه هو حقيقه
سيتم التعامل معك كانه ايش حقيقه لو انا
قلت لكم اليوم انا شخص مثلا مريض وانا
واقف هيصير كلكم تقولوا انه هذا الشخص
مريض الله يعينه سلامته بس انا مالي شيء
بس انا بس انا حكيم
التعامل تبعكم صار حقيقه اي انطباع انت
بتتركه هو حقيقه وما عمرك عندك فرصه ثانيه
للانتباع الاول اسمه الانتباه الاول فصار
عندنا مشكلتين مشكل طريقه اثار النشر
الجويه
تعرف عن حالي مره ثانيه هلا انا اسمي محمد
شاكر
شغف كبير في علم الارصاد بس صار عندي ايش
مهمه لحل مشكلتين في هذا القطاع
المشكله روحنا جبنا اوائل طلاب جامعات في
علوم البيانات
مبرمجين ناس اذكياء في الجامعات المشكله
كيف ممكن نحلها اعطوني حل
ما كان يعني حل كثير قصير الامان يعني
حكوا ان شاء الله بعشر سنين تنحل هاي
المشكله
خلينا نبدا المشكله تاخذ هذا الحلو بده
ياخذ وقت عشر سنوات
حتى يلقط ويدر انفورميشن وبعدين
الصوره نفكر كيف ممكن نحلل الصور اللي
انتم بتصوروها على السوشيال ميديا لما
الدنيا بتمطر وبتثلج او بيجي غبار لنحولها
لبيانات عن طريق الذكاء الاصطناعي وفعلا
فخور جدا بفريق العمل اللي معي اللي هو
منكم من جامعاتكم منكم انفسكم اللي يقدر
يحول هاي الخوارزميات اللي بتقدر اليوم
تجمع كل هذه البيانات
وبدي احكي لكم شغله كثير مهمه شايفين شو
الجمله اللي ورائي الدين
احنا دائما كنا بدنا نكون مستعدين عشان
احنا ما نعرف امتى الفرصه بتيجي
فكنا دائما عم نطور التكنولوجيا رغم انه
احنا ما كان في حاجه بس لايماننا بانه
الفرصه لما بتيجي لازم نحن نكون ايش
مستعدين
صارت معي بشكل سريع
2012 اجتنا شركه طيران
بدهم يحطوا الناس اللي كانوا مسافرين
فنادق وبعدين
الاصليه
بعد عشر سنوات
اثنين
قبل ما اقول لكم اثنين
بعد سنتين صار في عندنا كمان حدا حكى معنا
هي امانه
في منطقه في دوله عربيه انا عندي مشكله
بسبب السيول واحنا لازم يكون في عنا نظام
تنبيهات مبكر وباخذ بعين الاعتبار البنا
التحتيه للاحياء في حي بكون مجدد جديد
المطر لما بنزل عليه ما بتفيض حي ثاني
بننزل نفس المطر
وبعد ذلك هذا المنتج صار يستخدم
علينا احنا كمان
هذا شويه الهوى كانت بتوقف انتاج نفط
بتاثر على الاسعار بدهم يعرفوا قبلي بوقت
ايش الايام اللي فيها سرعه رياح معينه
عشان يقدروا انهم يجدولوا انتاج النفط قبل
الوقت وما يصير في اي انقطاع في انتاج
النفط
بعد كل هذه التجارب وهاي التجارب كلها
موجوده اشتغلنا لها اللي شايفينها ورائي
هل انا كنت اتوقع لما انا بدات
اول مره اني انا يكون في عندي خدمات لكل
هذول الناس او اوصل موضوع الطيران والنفط
والطاقه متجدده وغيرها
ما كنت اتوقع وما كنت بعرف لكن اشي واحد
بقدر اقول لكم بعرفه اليوم جدا مهم
هو البدايه عشان هيك انا اخترت عنوان
الحديث تبع اليوم انه عندما تقرر ان تبدا
الرحله ستظهر لك الطريق عمرك ما تفكر من
طريق راح تكون مبينه اذا انت مش مبلش
الرحله ما راح تبين الطريقه هاي طريقه
افتراضيه لكن الطريق راح تبين لك اول ما
تبدا
كل اللي شفته قبل شويه والانجازات ومركز
طقس العرب اكبر مركز في المنطقه العربيه
هو باسباب انا جزء من هذا السبب توفيق رب
العالمين شيء اساسي
وجود فريق مثل هذا الفريق اشي كثير اساسي
وجود اهل يحضنوا اشي كثير اساسي وجود شريك
زي زوجتي شيء اساسي عشان هيك كثير مهم
الناس اللي حواليكم الانسان
اذا جالس ناس معينه هتصير زيهم واذا جلست
ناس بطريقه ثانيه حتى تكون زيهم
كثير مهم انكم انتم اتنقو مين
الناس
طب هل فكرت يوم من الايام اني اوقف او
اطلع من هذا الموضوع كثير
فكرت اني اوقف واقول ما بدي اكمل هذا
الشيء
مقوله اسمها
ما تتوقف الا اذا انت
فخور دونت كنت
هذا القرار بتتخذه لما بتكون واصل لهذه
المرحله
بدي اختم بوصفه صغيره لنمو التقدم
كثير وصفات زي ما انتم شايفين قدامكم
تطلع مره منطقه الراحه كثير شيء مهم تعرف
انك تفرق ما بين الجهد البدني والذهني
كثير مهم يعني 12 ساعه
12 ساعه
لازم تكون تتقن عملك تتقنه مش الضابطه
اتقان عشان هيك عشان تقدر تتقن عملك
اليوم هذه الاشياء
من اهم الاشياء اذا ما تواضعت حيكون عندك
مشكله في طريقه نموك وتقدمه
بخلص بالتعريف الثالث عن حالي انا محمد
الشاكر نفسه الشخص اللي كان وانا عمري
اربع سنين ايش عندي هوايه وشغف في الارصاد
الجويه نفسه
هذا الشخص اليوم عم بيدير اكبر مركز للطقس
في الوطن العربي
اذكركم
حتى
شكرا لكم جميعا
[تصفيق]